Uh,
today I'm very,
very excited to host a us,
our speaker or author Sarah drew and I have a little intro for her to talk about
the Gaia Co Codex talk,
the talk about feminine wisdom and the evolution of technology.
I actually know Sarah as a personal friend and I,
I think she's in one of the most inspiring women who embodied feminine values.
I think if you just watch her on stage all you'll know what I mean.
But I'm really pleased that she's here today to talk about her book.
So a little bit about that and we'll go ahead and hand it over to her.
So basically the guy a codex is what we're going to talk about and this is both
an ancient found wisdom text and assumption was epic novel Gaia.
Codex reveals the hidden histories of a world long forgotten the secret wisdom
of an ancient lineage of women said in a near future of impending societal and
environmental collapse.
The novel is a tale of hope and remembrance as well as an inspired vision of
humanities origins and on the potential we hold for conscious evolution.
Very important topic with with growing numbers of international readers.
Gaia.
Codex is a flourishing phenomena that is capturing the passionate spirit of the
feminine rising and our deepening reconnection to our mother earth and very
timely with earth day coming up,
a lifelong explorer of cultural and consciousness.
Sarah has traveled the world from the high plateaus of Tibet to the jungles of
the Amazon to remote villages in Bhutan.
She studied religious studies at UC Berkeley and has lectured internationally
and at the graduate level on topics such as technology and consciousness and the
design of mind is consulting and innovation for Meto.
Muse brings a seasoned expertise in the areas of innovation,
media,
emergent technologies and environment,
evolutionary culture.
Men Amuse works with clients and companies to help shape regenerative vital
cultures that catalyze the optimum potential of the human species and honor the
sense the sanctity of mother earth.
Sarah lives in mill valley,
so she's local and please welcome Sarah.
Thank you.
Thank you,
Rachel.
It's wonderful to be here with all of you today and to be here at Google and may
our time here together benefit all beings,
benefit life.
We're going to be doing a little exploration about how we as a species can
create vibrant regenerative cultures at this critical point in our evolution.
And now a little bit later we're going to go deep into the guy a codex and are
going to be looking at how we as women and men can reconnect with the ancient
wisdom that is the feminine wisdom traditions.
But right now I want to look at how we can create conscious wise technology.
There's an ancient body of wisdom and I emerging cultural knowing that our
mother earth,
terra Gaja is a living,
breathing entity.
We are part of her and she is part of us.
She is consciousness,
the pure vibration of consciousness and she has matter of evolving,
learning,
experimenting and breathing and in the stream of knowing we are.
But one of the many forms of life Koa emergent with her
over time,
pythons and elephants,
regular trees and lotuses,
ancient tried to sources saber tooth tigers and ferns whose origins stripped
spread back 350 million years and their origins,
we human beings,
we homo sapiens.
I've only been here for a blip in time
in the history of mother Gaia 200,000 years in a 2.5 and a 4.5 billion year
history.
And if we dig deep into our DNAs unknowing knowing we find that Gaya is ever
evolving and that we are just part of this living consciousness,
this evolving spirit of life running through us.
And I'd like to pose that technology is also part of guys blueprint
now when its optimum form technology is consciousness manifest and deeply
resonant with life flourishing here on mother earth.
Let me say this one more time and its optimum form cap Knology is consciousness
manifest,
consciousness manifest and deeply resonant with life flourishing on mother
earth.
Now there's a lot of debate right now about different scenarios of how we're
evolving as a specie and especially in regards to technology.
And kind of the simplistic polarity of that right now can be one on one hand
there's the uh,
AI,
singularity,
um,
human beings in carbon life would become obsolete.
Uh,
this is the scenario that you scenario that we've seen played out in many
Hollywood movies at this point.
One of the points factors of this is that technology is seen as something
separate from us.
And Technology is uh,
also,
uh,
and mother Gaia in this sense is seen not as living Brent beating entity,
but as a resource to be extracted to develop technology.
What I'd like to pose is that technology is indeed actually part of ourself and
that we are sacred technology.
And in particular our mother earth is one of the most extraordinary technologies
that we can learn from
4.5 billion years.
Library of our mother guy has a 4.5 billion years library of wisdom of living
technology is here for us to cherish and to learn from.
And we have a choice about how we evolve as a species.
We're all part of the participants in this game and this divine play.
There's a,
there's a wonderful word,
Sanskrit words,
Lila,
which means the divine play that creates worlds.
Um,
what Lila's presupposes is that we are actually creaking our creations with
consciousness or at least the aspiration towards awakened consciousness that
understands the laws of causalities.
All our actions have a effect and that we work within a web of interconnected
being and that we're here to the best of our ability to benefit all beings and
to benefit all alive.
So from this view,
this middle way that we are living,
breathing technology,
sacred technology and consciousness and that we're apart and intrinsic to mother
Gaia who is also a technology and consciousness.
There's a couple of anchor points to look at.
One that,
uh,
technology is a tool for the evolution of consciousness is a teaching tool.
And in,
um,
it's optimum form is,
can be used as a bridge to activate a qualities that the human being already has
within oneself.
Um,
a lot of areas that have been covered in the esoteric traditions,
which we'll go into two in a minute.
Technology at this point in time in its evolution is there is an externalization
of that.
The other that mother Gaia has a 4.5 billion year old library and blueprint of a
highly functional and sustainable technology and we've only scratched the
surface as to what it's here and it's our imperative to nourish her in,
to sustain her and to learn from her,
not to burn her,
not to pollute her rivers,
not to cut down her forest or blast out.
Her mountaintops is the equivalent to destroying the library of Alexander.
Maybe even worse because it's four Pi pi billion years of information and data,
which can inform how we are living on the,
and this goes into a lot of the work and teachings,
which you're probably aware of,
a Jane Venus with bio mimicry,
looking to the mother earth to find design for evolving technology and also
Bucky fuller was working with planet ship or the third thing,
we must make the transition from extractive technologies to technologies where
the energy sources are regenerative so that we don't continue to deplete the
resources in the planet.
And that we're looking at forward not just to seven generations ahead,
but we're looking forward to how do we keep the planet livable for Homo Sapiens
for the next millennia.
Okay.
A doorway understanding technology and regenerative energy is maybe to dive into
the Meza Fez,
Ben,
a physics or esoteric practices.
Um,
okay.
These have often been in a span of many human traditions,
a bridge to understanding this precious give a gift of life and our mother Gaia
across epic's cultures and epics of time.
There's been these practices that allow us to go directly in to the wisdom of
our sacred technology of the human being.
Now,
probably many of you are familiar with yoga and probably practice it.
Um,
the first level of Yoga,
when we go into a yoga class,
we'll just be working with the physical body,
right?
We're going to get in shape.
We're going to do are saunas go one layer deeper.
We start to work with the energy systems of the body,
which is in Sanskrit,
but it is,
there's a home network calls naughties.
The noddies are a nodal network that are there,
which is an energy system.
You learn how to activate that.
They're there and they're in alignment with the Chakras,
which in that system are understood to be poor tolls to um,
activating the body's full of energy and consciousness potentials.
Um,
very key.
And that is the balance between the male and the female.
It's called the Pingala and the Eda,
the sun and the moon.
They understand that,
uh,
a whole human being is a balance between the male and the female.
Um,
mindfulness meditation is,
I know many of you here are practicing,
um,
helps clear the mines so that we understand where thoughts come in and what were
receptive to what types of creation we are actually bringing forth.
When the mind is still in the mind is clear,
we can start to bring forth with choice a conscious creations.
Okay.
Causality is,
um,
there's a couple of things that you can go also into Western alchemy which is
working in the western alchemic tradition is again,
is working at how to use the technology of the human being.
Um,
the coding of the symbolic form of that was the transmutation and material which
became part of the history of chemistry,
but it's inner practices were esoteric practices about how we transmute the
human beings so that we have a direct connection with consciousness itself.
And there's an equation.
It was like an energetic equation,
whether it was Tantra,
whether it was yoga,
whether it's Alchemy,
that the human being is a microcosm and we are a mirror replica of the
macrocosmic,
which is consciousness.
And if we understand how to align these energies and go into that,
we have the full energy of a potential.
We aren't just bodies and material,
but we are also a consciousness.
We're also light.
We're also vibration.
Um,
and the,
this from my understanding,
this fusion of pure consciousness with our material bodies and our understanding
of working with a network of how we can benefit all beings and all life is
really critical.
Again,
across these traditions,
inner connectivity,
all of life is connected.
You'll find this through most many of these traditions,
there's causality or effects have action.
This could be car come across in Karma and western Buddhism or,
uh,
the golden rule in Christianity and love that pure vibration of the heart where
we really hold care and compassion for other beings.
And that replicates itself out in our actions.
And finally,
the wood is so essential for this point in time is the reclaiming of our
relationship with the feminine part of ourselves and our reconnection into
mother Gaia.
So gaia codex,
codex is novel Britain is the ancient found wisdom text.
It's about an ancient lineage of women called the priestesses of hysteria.
If an holding rejuvenation cause for the planet for Millennium,
the story takes place a flash moment and right after now when there's
environmental crisis,
a culture right at the brink of either transformation or collapse.
It's also remembrance and to the deep roots of our collective past by a coded,
since the reclaiming and the recasting of the lost history of the sacred
feminine,
which in many cultures is a lost part of our shared human story.
So I'm going to read now from the prologue to the book.
I'll give you a taste of how we go into the world.
Okay?
Yeah.
To the easy part,
three of the flow of ages and the rise and fall of cultures.
A secret codex has been inscribed for the tales and stories,
the rites and rituals of priestesses who are emanations of the channel,
goddess caretakers and guardians of our mother earth,
Terra Gaya in India,
in China and ancient consumer in ancient Greece and Egypt in the Serengeti and
in the Amazon and in the Celtic wilds.
Their flows a timeless tradition amongst those who have walked the earth.
We've year and remember the circle of life past from grandmother to mother,
daughter,
sister,
aunt Tonnies,
health safe in the heart of sisters who have incarnated through the ages.
This text is not written on pieces of paper or pup Jairus.
Instead it is inscribed and Holograms of light and the leaves of trees.
The hunt of bees and the codes have spiraled DNA hidden for many.
The Codex is known to those with the eyes to see the ears to hear and the heart
to feel that which lies just beyond the veil.
It is said that the guy at Codex contains Joel,
sees a planetary destiny for all beings and life on planet earth.
These women,
these priestesses of Astera have sheltered and protected the codex and when
necessary,
kept it hidden and ready for those moments of extraordinary crisis and
transformation when it will be needed once more for the nourishment and
regeneration of humankind.
Now,
the book has been out since August and it's been really amazing,
um,
to receive and it's being read all over the world,
have readers in Malta,
in South Africa and Finland and down in South America and over in Japan and all
over North America.
And it's been really amazing to get these long letters from women saying,
I know this.
There's something that I remember and what they will describe as their own
childhood memories,
their own breakthrough memories.
And we,
many of us have had this when we've gone into a place that's either ecstasy or
crisis where the veils become a little thinner.
And we remember these essence truths about our own soul,
about our people.
Um,
and each of the women that are writing are adding in their own story.
And how I understand the codex is working is more as an open source code.
It's a narrative that is also,
there is an activator for
PR essence with life.
I want to read another passage here.
And these are from uh,
at the beginning of each of the chapters.
There's these codes or Gaia,
codex nodes.
There are priestesses of Astera whose bodies and minds have been dedicated as
temples of memory into these women's bones flesh in Oregon,
Oregon's into their very selves report historical events and knowledge for
safekeeping.
In these women,
these memory keepers are storage jewels of revelation bins for healing and
creation.
Some say the true gift of these women is their ability to seamlessly connect
with all life itself.
Do you read the ancient records in the tiniest grain of sand in the veins of a
leaf and a constellation of stars or in the softness of a kiss upon the lips?
These memory keepers are both empty and full is they carry the wisdom through
the ages.
Gaia Codex node four 4.54281
there's an ancient Buddhist,
um,
Sutra called the [inaudible] trail,
which is one of my favorite.
It's my on a Buddhist.
It was actually put into written form and fourth,
fifth century
BCE.
And
I,
what it is is this amazing holographic text of how this reality is structured is
a thousand page pages in written form and it talks about,
um,
very central to it injuries net,
which probably many of you know about.
And an interest net is this infinite,
infinite dimension on that where at every node there is a parole that reflects
all the other pearls.
And
okay,
it's talked about is a inner technology that has been discovered by people who,
in this case,
we're following the Buddhist path and we're going on the path of being a bowtie
soft fat.
The book also talks about the stages of becoming a bodhisattva and how we
cultivate that.
Um,
and there's some beautiful descriptions of the body.
They call it the Buddha body,
but it's,
it's our body when we are in awaken consciousness and it'll talk about billions
of worlds being on one little strand of hair.
And you know,
each fingertip holds the eons of the ages.
And so it's this way of where we become multidimensional beings through
conscious contemplated practice.
Okay.
And I would say as women,
um,
we have a very close relationship to our bodies and a care of our bodies as
containers of the,
the universe and containers of life.
Okay.
Working with women when I've done that kind of the entry point often is first
that place of where we're feeling,
feeling,
um,
the pain and the sorrow of generations of unbalanced.
And you know,
both all of us as human beings and for men too,
we're both male and female.
And balance is what we are striving for right now.
What we're cultivating,
what we're nourishing.
Um,
so it's cultivating the activation of the feminine rising,
but it's also cultivating the honoring of the,
the masculine part of ourself in relationship to the female.
When did the sacred technologies that women have is the,
the circle.
And,
um,
the sacred circle is a way of activating energies and activating direct
connection into wisdom streams as it's understood in the sacred feminine is the
activation of the matrix.
But the original meaning of the Matrix,
which means womb.
Um,
I also kind of makes me laugh that,
um,
his status is a week for the wandering rooms.
So hysteria happens when the womb is his wandering.
So it's important to anchor these circles and to anchor it together with other
women.
It becomes,
um,
a place where we can start to directly connect with the codes of the planet
directly,
connect with the wisdom that wants to come through,
directly connect with the creations that want to come through right now and give
life and form.
Yeah.
This technology of the sacred circle with women gathering is a means to activate
new life
and to connect to life.
I think there's,
there's really many women right now that are giving voice to this rising sacred
feminine within us and many men that I've met,
two that are supportive of it.
Um,
it's a call to,
um,
be,
to continue life and healthy life here out in our planet.
When I really started to feel the tears of Gaia,
when you start to see,
get the stated rain forest,
when you see mountain tops in Virginia that had been blasted off.
Yeah,
this is our body,
this,
this is our source to life.
And we may be cosmic universal beings.
We may be being as a pure mind and intelligence,
but we are citizens.
We are part of the mother earth.
And
if we say this story her and the way that we're going right now,
it will not be here for our children.
And we have a responsibility as women and as men
to cultivate life.
Okay?
Part of it is feeling.
It is feeling the pain of what we as a culture have done.
And it's not easy.
We do a lot of things to intoxicate herself,
all of his half.
I have to,
um,
not feel,
but we need to feel.
And from that we can create a new way of,
of doing things.
Um,
that was unexpected.
Where to go from there.
Um,
when you talk a bit about just the gathering of women,
um,
again from the book,
okay.
It's called the temples of Astera.
These women are called the priestesses of Astera.
Most of the forgotten that the temples of Astera exist.
This is by design.
Our temples have been carefully protected for in many cultures and political
climates.
The revelation of our temples existence has meant a certain death.
Conquer is built their temples on our sacred grounds,
but even stone edify has fed edifices at some point fall the wheel is always
turning.
Our temples are found in forest groves and the reflection of the clear glacial
lake or on the mountain top,
you may find she's such a temple inside a simple hut or at the back of an
unassuming merchant's shop.
It is known that our physical bodies are one of our most profound and sacred
temples.
The temples of a stair I've been designed to look common to the common eye.
But for those with the eyes to see the temples of a stair are radiant with like
they are the repositories of what has been and what may be.
Once again on our mother earth,
the temples of Astera take inspiration from the natural harmonics of nature
herself,
from the Subatomic to the cosmic.
The walls of our temples are resonating,
fluctuating between light and matter.
Hence their fluidity and ability to transform in the eye of the beholder.
Our temples are portals where you can enter deeper dimensions both in the past
and in the future.
Palimpsest where multiple dimensions coexist,
stand in the center of one and you're anchored inside the wheel of life.
All the elements,
earth,
water and fire,
wind are all there in equal proportion.
So I think
simplicity in clothes is that,
um,
we're here as defenders of Gaia where the voice of Mother Gaia,
whether we are male or female or vessels into which the future becomes manifest
in every one of us.
Okay.
It's time for us to wake up from the days
the Maya have repetitive action to go deeper into our central consciousness
and to understand when a meme or a seed is implanted inside of us and to
understand and give caution to what we're propagating for the future.
For those of you here who are essential to shaping reality through technology.
Consider the impact of what we're creating on generations to come.
Let's create why is conscious technologies which nourished life and consider the
wellbeing of all being and for the woman in the audience,
it's important for us in particular to return to our ancient ways they tried
into technologies of our lineage.
But to do it for at this moment now at this critical choice point,
it's time for us to gather in circles large and small,
and to open the portals for what has been long hidden and forgotten for we're
defenders and mother Gaia and we are defenders of life and we're here to create
a vibrant life of farming future for our children and our children's children
for generations to come.
Thank you.
So I,
uh,
I know that from the book you have some really great imagery,
just wonderful,
beautiful
images.
So can you talk a little bit about that and the inspiration for those?
Where do those come from?
And they're just beautiful.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Um,
it's such a great question.
Uh,
when I'm,
uh,
creating,
and it's interesting,
I'm,
I'm working with a lot of clients right now who are writing and,
uh,
women and men who are bringing in,
um,
a lot of these new flows of information.
And I found that I actually received the information first as a visual.
So,
um,
what I mean by that is that there will be,
and this is like going into the creative process.
When I went to write the book,
um,
there is,
this scene would come in and it'd be like watching a movie.
And for me it was so visceral.
And so since Storyful,
um,
and I was just the transcriber writing it,
you know,
okay,
wow,
this is happening,
this is happening to the character.
Um,
and even though a lot of my background had trained my mind and the intellectual
process and it studied religions and I've been a curator on different projects
working with a kind of global wisdom when it came to that process,
it was just going into these living worlds.
And it's a way a traveling both in the writing process,
in the past and the future.
Um,
so those are images or anchors and I,
I see it as like a symbolic language actually.
Um,
and it was really essential I thought in the publication of the book to have the
images as part of the story,
kind of the,
like the ancient illuminated manuscripts.
And one of the calls to action that you had for,
um,
women here and just,
men that they channel their inner feminine,
um,
was to gather and circles.
And I wonder if you could share more like what you mean by that.
Is that more of like a symbolic thing or,
I'm thinking of my brain like nude gatherings or something like,
yeah.
Um,
where we gather on the fire and like share stories.
I don't know.
I'm curious,
um,
if you have any suggestions.
Um,
it's a great question and I think,
you know,
gathering in circle is something that's so natural once we go into it.
Um,
especially for women,
you know,
and,
uh,
I,
I'm seeing it as a ground roots call to action,
but I'm also seeing it as medicine.
We're doing it to come together because there's a lot of healing and
transportation that happens first.
You know,
and that's really essential and a lot of the energies that we're working with
right now,
none of us can do it alone.
We need to do it together.
And it really is this place where our personal,
our personal joy is our personal pains interact with the larger ethos of what's
happening on the planet.
Um,
with a guy,
a codex,
there's been women that had been gathering around the book,
around the planet and it's really wonderful and we're going to be coming in the
end of May,
probably mid May.
We're going to be having just free online gathering so that those are,
that are gathering and just,
and just some basic blueprints.
I'm really big on people being able to access the room knowing,
cause I think once what I've found,
when the circle set up right,
you can start to access these wisdoms and you have these amazing things of stuff
that maybe we haven't been taught that starts to flow through us.
So,
um,
but anyway,
it will be having that and I'll give my information at the end hearing.
It'd be wonderful to see you here,
all of you there and men too.
And get your [inaudible].
Yeah,
I'm getting,
it's like a community.
So it's,
it's almost like embracing that feminine,
uh,
value and trade of community and associating with others,
men or women about this issue and how we can help the planet.
And
that could,
thank you.
So it's almost kind of going into the root word of that,
right?
The communion,
the commune,
the community,
the um,
yeah,
there's just that,
that,
that empathy is the heart.
Right.
Um,
while you were talking,
especially it kind of when you became overcome with emotion.
Thank you for sharing that.
Um,
I was curious,
I'm just curious generally to hear your thought process and why it sounds like
it's a fiction book more or less,
um,
kind of how you decided which should be fiction or nonfiction because these are
also very serious factual issues.
And also I'm getting shivers as you're saying it.
Thanks for tuning in.
It was actually when I started to,
to write the book and I got the,
that I needed to write the book.
I actually took three years and,
uh,
was very fortunate to receive a bequest from Sean Healy who is an early,
silicon valley and,
or you can go over and silicon genesis,
genesis over at Stanford did a lot,
does it work with bio chip.
Um,
she's passed.
And I say she because she became a transgender at the end of her life and it
could have been fiction or it could have been nonfiction.
And I felt that fiction at this point in time allows us to be,
have more brain elasticity to just stretch your imaginations a bit more on what
could be without having to go into it.
And I do it too going into our critical mind of like,
well no,
this isn't how it is right now or you know,
going into logic so much.
So it was a very specific choice with that.
Um,
yeah,
just to give us more of X.
And I wanted to give a real visceral since oil where sometimes with facts,
um,
I mean facts done well are going to be visceral into the soil,
but I wanted to have more of this real something that taste and eat and smell
and yeah,
it's a great question.
I'm just about to finish this like year and a half immersion called inner yoga,
this whole thing.
And I just started a new job here and I'm kind of crossing these two worlds,
so I'm glad you're here today.
And I was just wondering more about your personal background of like your
spiritual influences or rituals that lead this and if there's any,
um,
I don't know,
just certain practices that you do regularly or rituals or people you follow.
Anything else you'd recommend?
Thank
you.
Um,
I'll make it brief.
My journey's been a long one.
You know,
um,
you know,
when I was 19,
20,
I started out and completely different field and then got,
which I know some Googlers did that I needed to take three years off and travel
around the world.
And I ended up going to Tibet and India and down in the Amazon and then came
back and went to UC Berkeley and studied religious studies.
Um,
I was journalism to begin with.
It's going to become television anchor or something.
And then,
and then from religious studies,
I went into technology and how it had a high tech startup in the 90s,
um,
that was working with earlier forms of virtual reality.
Um,
so my practice became the crack open.
It wasn't pretty,
it was messy,
you know,
it was like me going and just the top of the head being ripped open.
And all of a sudden everything that I thought was true wasn't true and I needed
to,
my solution to that was to travel to bed to 1984 and sit with Buddhist monks.
And a lot of my practice right now is in the,
um,
the tantric Buddhist Yoga tradition.
Um,
my main teachers are in Butan.
and I meditate every day.
I work with the goddesses.
Sally Kempton,
I don't know if you know of her work.
She's been one of my mentors for many years.
Um,
so the embodiment,
I think for women,
the Hindu and Buddhist tantric tradition for embodying the goddess,
I find really useful because there are these whole templates and they're almost
like kind of finished aesthetic multimedia templates of how we can have all the
information embodied in there.
And it's a really interesting technology actually I think because you have like
a,
as you know,
a Mandela,
but I'm Dala also has a link to connection into a mantra,
which is a sound,
which also has a link connection into the image of the goddess that's easier for
you to just kind of,
oh,
I will be.
Her will will resonate together.
Right?
And,
and so it's,
it's a fairly fuss I found sophisticated system of embodiment and,
um,
and they cultivate,
you know,
the steep karmic compassion.
So,
um,
I really look forward to hearing more about your journey because I,
it just feels like it's something really big and whatever your eye,
I mean not to put you on the spot in the room and we can talk it,
but it feels I can,
I can feel that after these couple of years there's something quite
extraordinary you're bringing through.
So thank you.
And one more question.
So when you were getting the visuals and trying to write this,
was it
okay?
Was it a all at once,
like through like it would took three years to write,
but did you just get an entire storyline and know what you're exactly getting to
right?
Or was it piece by piece and unfolded over years of what happened?
Right.
Um,
the way that I received the information,
and it's interesting that in this illuminated creation writing program that
we're doing right now,
um,
a lot of this,
almost all the students that signed up for the program are receiving the
information in similar ways,
which is like a blueprint.
At first,
I received it as kind of like a mandelic blueprint.
And I actually took a piece of paper,
drew down certain images,
put down certain key words of what the key,
um,
means,
if you will,
in the books he and from,
you know,
were there.
Um,
and then I didn't pressure myself to say,
okay,
let's start at the beginning.
I just let whatever scene would come up.
And there's these key anchor scenes.
One of them,
um,
give the guy a codex was there's this extraordinary gathering of women at the
Chateau Lumiere.
And all of a sudden I found myself in the midst of this room with women from all
different cultures and places,
um,
who were gathering at this particular time on the planet to bring about
rejuvenation.
And it was so since oral,
I mean,
it was,
I was curious and in my job as a writer at that point was just to,
I was described really,
you know,
um,
so a lot of the key themes would come like that and pretty much in their
complete form.
And then narrative arc constructure you know,
it basically took a heroine's journey.
It was the narrative structure.
And then of course the editing's a whole other,
I want to say editing's a bitch,
but
it's a whole other process.
While I was very lucky to have some wonderful people to work with.
Anyway,
wonderful to be here and thanks for your great questions.
Um,
if you're interested in diving in deeper,
you can go to www Daya codex.com for those of you here today,
the book is over available over here.
It's also available on Amazon as well as the website.
Um,
I am offering a nine week one on one mentoring program and illuminated creation,
the art of visionary writing,
um,
where we dive in deep and both look at structural start stuff.
And it's really geared towards if you feel that you're bringing in
a new code or creation for this next,
next phase of our human existence.
And this is a good good one.
And women and men are invited.
And finally for those are,
um,
have projects and startups who are working with or margin evolutionary culture.
I consult with different companies and bring together wisdom circles of both men
and women on,
on how we can make this transition into evolutionary culture.
And that's at Metta means media.net www metamusic media.net so glad to be here
with Holly.
Great.
Thank you.